[Applause]
I mean even if people didn't know you
like you look like a cool band dude like
you just you exude rock and roll Happ
birth oh thank you thank you I'm a
official where were you when I was
growing up uh in the United States in
the
Bron believe until the planetarium he
only thought this guy was one way yeah
yeah so you have to be in space you
wrote Rocket Man you have to like oh you
took you took my joke
oh I can't believe you did that to me oh
my God I didn't mean to but it does have
a it does have a line in it that you
you'll make it it says uh all this
science I don't understand oh you know
there you you don't have to understand
as long as it works yeah yeah yeah you
know where I got the idea from that
where was that Ray Bradbury is that
right oh yeah he wrote a book called The
Illustrated Man yes which was uh science
fiction short stories and there was a
story in there called the Rocket Man oh
my gosh that's where I lifted it from I
love that you lifted
Ito give myot from Ray bab some people
asked him Ray why are you projecting
such apocalyptic futures for us in the
world is that where you think we're
headed he said no I Rite apocalyptic
Futures so you know to avoid them oh I
love that well can't avoid them all
asteroid but anyway um whatever congrats
though on the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
that is so cool thank you very much
thank
you I would have I would have thought
that that already would have happened
honestly yeah that that's the general uh
consensus
uh no it's s through the cracks there
for a minute I slipped through the
cracks yeah so I hear you had a crazy
night and I just love the company it was
Freddy Mercury I think and Billy Jin
King yeah it's kind of how what what
what's happening there yes what's yeah
that's the story is in my book but
um yeah this is back are you filtering
yourself right now what should yeah
after your discussion earlier in the
show I thought wait I I got to make sure
I I can do this get through the
corre okay yeah no it was back in the
early 70s back when New York was a
little bit more dangerous than it is
today it was really wild back then and I
used to hang out with Freddy a lot and
and uh Billy Jean King was a friend
because uh Elton was a huge tennis fan
and because it was Elton John you know
people sort of gravitate towards him so
Billy Jean became uh a good friend she
tried teach me um uh to play tennis once
and I said in my book I said it's
probably the only time she's ever failed
at
any but anyway we just ended up together
one night and there was an establishment
that I used to go to called the Gilded
grape which was basically a drag bar but
it had the it was well known for every
every different possible kind of person
would go there you'd get sort of maid
guys going there Wise Guys just
everybody people off the street it was
unbelievable and nobody paid any
attention to the fact that it was
basically a drag Club yeah and all the
people that worked there used to dress
up as sort of famous movie stars and uh
theatrical divas and things like that
but there was never any trouble there at
all I mean everybody got along
beautifully kind of sounds like a great
you Andy Warhol would go there and all
of the sort of the art community and it
was great it was just a wonderful mix of
people and the three of us ended up
going there one night and the tables
were just sort of for Mica tables and
stools you know really cheap really
cheap and two of The Waitresses the drag
waitresses got into a fight yeah with
each other and they just happened to
land on top of our table and completely
demolished it it was like we'd be
talking away and and Freddy loved those
kind of places so he was he was just
egging them on you know yes dear you go
on go on you get her you get her dear
you know but they literally landed on
our table and suddenly they jumped up
and they were friends again and we're
we're just sitting with no table just on
these chairs every but it like that they
came and replaced it as if nothing had
happened you know they just put another
table you saw nothing it usual thing
just get get the next table put it yeah
but it was an interesting threesome
yes oh my God I love you let's take a
quick break no segue there Bernie's new
book it's called scattershot Life music
Elton and me it's out now stories just
like that are in there so why not you
have to jump and and buy
[Music]
that
[Applause]
thank you guys yall have a great night
I'm going
home